last year at the super bowl dan marino
chris sims
he was given the scouting report on the
young chris sims throwing the football
we got to see chris actually throw the
football you can spin it i can spin it i
mean i can't spend it like dan marino i
mean dan marino's one of the greatest
yeah well whatever
one of the great spinners of all time i
mean really i mean really thanks chris i
appreciate that man you
elway
rogers for sure yeah all those guys
yeah and now probably the guy wearing 50
patrick right patrick right i mean does
that am i missing anybody else do you
think some class there no there's a lot
of guys i mean i know over the years i
know but don't be nice i remember way
back in the day like you know bradshaw
and bert jones and those name if those
guys could sling it too now yeah yeah
who is it that you see now that makes
you say oh my gosh this guy's really got
it uh well there's
you know i look patrick mahomes i mean
you look at what he's been able to do
the first couple years and coming in
what last year throwing 50 touchdowns
but just the way he throws the ball you
know his arm angles and getting in the
position that he gets in the throw and
he's throwing it accurately
and uh has a nice sense in the pocket
you know all those things he runs well
enough yeah he runs good he's got you
beat there yes he does
maybe not when i was really young but uh
sure sure it's uh yeah he's he's special
you had that rocket release that was
more of a traditional throwing motion
he's got the rocket release from
wherever his arm happens to be whichever
hand the ball happens to be in wherever
his body is wherever his feet are i mean
from the standpoint of pure quarterback
play does it drive you a little crazy to
see some of these guys who are all over
the place but they're still able to
throw the ball yeah i mean i think that
uh that's part of it it really is i mean
i i you may say there's a pocket passer
but you still have to move your body a
little bit you still have to throw from
different angles arm angles i mean aaron
rodgers does it but he does move around
quite a bit too um i had a little
baseball background too just like
mahomes does and and so it does give you
that ability to throw from you know a
lot of different angles and sometimes
you have to just because the way the
rush is right yeah so i mean that that's
just part of it um you you know i did
recently i mean there's all this talk
about like brady right brady oh is he
gonna go to a new team all that i know
you semi went through that yourself like
there was always the talk about you
signing with the minnesota vikings you
know like what would be your two cents
on the brady situation and what he
should do and how you see it i you know
it's hard let me tell you i mean i know
he's probably you know you just have to
sit back and look at each situation and
see if
uh if it might fit you and what what you
want to do because he deserves that
right right he really does he deserves
that right because as long as he's
played the the career he's had i mean
all the super bowls he's won you know i
i mean to to stay in new england to me
that's what i would probably you would
do too that's me too i'm with you but
right at the same time he deserves the
right to do what he wants to do and um
look at each and every situation i just
felt like after 17 years
my body was a little bit my legs weren't
working like i wanted to right and
instead of going to minnesota just you
know shut it down dolphin for life yeah
and with your connection still to the
dolphins are you kind of sitting back
watching the brady situation hoping that
he gets the heck out of the afc east
once and for all look at what can you
say they've dominated so i mean that's
just the way it is it's uh it's been a
fact so um but the one thing is i i
believe in what we're doing and i think
we're we're coming in the right
direction yeah yeah talk talk about that
because i'm a huge brian flores fan i've
worked with him in new england yeah what
what jumps out to you about him so i
just think his you know desire to win is
you know how you know his work ethic and
uh and and what you see uh his players
do for him right that's the one thing he
gets them to believe and what the
program is and and that the fact that
you know no matter what we're going out
there to win football games that's what
it's all about and he has uh he has
really shown that they were supposed to
tank this year you didn't know that i
hate that i know right that's
the answer yes here's what you want to
say
who in the right mind would do that
right and especially not a coach they're
just not wired that way
yeah right yeah it's gonna be used
against you yeah i know and the team
turned around five and four over the
last nine games what did you notice from
the dolphins by way of just kind of like
a moment where it's sinking in it's
working and now they're moving in the
right direction so i think it uh we're
we're getting there i mean obviously
when we want to be in a position like
the patriots are in every year
as time goes on um
i think the fact that the you know young
kids started believing the program and
what we were doing and and uh we got
guys that believed in you know playing
hard for 60 minutes and having a chance
to win at the end and i think
you know fitzpatrick was great for us
you know ryan i think he he had
everybody believing in him that you
could win every game going out there and
the way he plays the game he loves the
game so i think that's helped us it
helped us down the line obviously to win
the games that we won
um
these shoes right here yes yes isa
toners i mean you you were killing it
when i was a young man in 18. you
yes and then for years i was doing the
gloves right and and then it kind of you
know it's been 25 years and they came
back to me wanting to do gloves and
slip-ons and uh we did that a couple
years ago and it's been fantastic
isotoner's been great to me over the
years and these things are comfortable
you got to when you put them on you'll
you'll understand it's like walking on
air i can feel
when your feet hurt if you're an athlete
you know right legs are hurting whatever
walk around on these i got mine on yeah
right there looking good flexibility's
not bad
that's that's hard don't ask
don't ask me don't pull it back muscle
but yes yeah so it's been really good
and we're going to uh some of the
veteran hospitals over the next couple
days and we're going to give these away
wow and uh doing some of the boys and
girls club too man isotoner making your
hands and feet comfortable now zen shoes
slip-ons then do people still quote face
ventura lines to you uh yeah i get laces
out a lot do you yeah yeah they say dan
laces out right alrighty then
yeah what was that like like filming a
movie with that knucklehead every day it
was interesting because like he was in
character all the time right so it was
like after a while you're like come on
man can't you just talk
to me or you don't have to be ace
ventura the whole time right but it was
a lot of fun it was a lot of fun it was
years ago actually and and i still get a
lot of you know kids and adults even
obviously talking about that movie it's
a staple that we had a draft early like
all things miami and we didn't end up
picking that but when we got done we
went oh man like ace because
yeah it was but i would say the whole
thing here he had the first pick the
all-time miami power ranking his first
pick was dan marino well thank you thank
you i mean to me
you symbolize miami to me especially as
a young kid from pittsburgh an italian
kid from pittsburgh
i think miami icon is an american thing
it's good thing he's italian he can get
a good tan and he doesn't worry about
the sun if i came down here to miami i'd
be like a walking sun cancer
billboard it wouldn't be good
oh man
yeah give us uh give us your mount
rushmore of uh
city of miami miami figures i mean
you're you're his george washington who
who are the people who
to me when i'm looking at it i'm looking
at you know dwyane wade i mean without a
doubt i mean he's done
you know for this community for
championships all the things he's done
here is you know miami heat
player and just the person he's been i
mean for sure and then you know it's
coach schuller yeah i mean you gotta
look at coach
coach for sure and what uh
the years that uh i mean
i love him he was my coach for 13 years
uh he's definitely an icon down here and
then you got to go with pat riley oh i
could have forgot about him good for god
how do you forget
riley i was sitting here going man who
would be my fourth guy i mean you're
right how could i forget that riley uh
just amazing what he's been able to do
and look at him playing right now the
way they're playing and no one expected
them to play this way yeah so uh yeah
those i mean who else then um
who would it be don johnson from miami
that was in our draft today too
right wayne heisinga i don't even know
yeah it could be wayne hey the first guy
for me was larry zonka just because i
grew up in that area
very unstoppable and one of the all-time
great football names it too for sure
49ers like in the super bowl do you
inherently root against them uh
no no but i'm an afc guy though yeah so
you know i'm
like it'd be nice to see you know kansas
city and then play well because a young
kid yeah but i'm just looking for a good
game you know you we want a good game
here in miami show it off nice the new
stadium is beautiful you guys have been
in it before yeah i mean it's great so
it's uh looking for a good time yeah
this game reminds me a lot of super bowl
19 in that there is a sense that it's
going to be evenly matched it's going to
be a close game it's two great teams the
two best teams in the league
and i it it can go sideways easily right
i mean there's something about the super
bowl especially back in the 70s and 80s
we saw it and i have a feeling it can
happen this year where if if one team
just gets a gets a lucky uppercut early
right that could just knock the other
team out and it's not going to be that
that sometimes it just snowballs you
know rolls and right you get a turnover
things don't happen right then you start
forcing things and and uh you get out of
your game plan but the one thing you
could say is like kansas city they were
down 24. i know i mean that's hard to
believe right back from that that's that
doesn't happen often right and they were
able to do it so it shows that they if
that does happen to them that they have
the poise to know that they can look
back and say hey we did this a couple
weeks ago we can do it again you're like
everyone you know
what when when are the you know you like
the 85 bears team you you shredded them
apart and everybody wanted to see that
super bowl because we thought oh my gosh
nobody talks about the 84 niners defense
that you played i think people forget
they were they were
than we had right not excuses but they
were number one defense right you know
in the league and they had some great
great players on that defense was there
a moment in the game where you went oh
man we're in trouble hardly even
remember now yeah um
you know i think in the second half i
still felt because it was pretty close
right so you know it'd have to go very
late yeah it wasn't great and then it's
then it snowballed later on so i i felt
like we still had a chance in the second
half right right well hey thanks for the
you guys are great
don't worry i'm gonna wear these i'll be
supporting the hotel actually they're
perfect
i appreciate it very much great seeing
you as always thanks uh thanks for
including us and appreciate you talking
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports